ils se sont tour à tour admirés détestés
réconciliés et après le 2 conflit mondial
Winston Churchill et Charles de Gaulle ont donc
chacun écrit et publié leur mémoire de guerre
c'est ce duel d'écrivain de mémorialiste à fleur
et moucheté auquel s'est donc intéressé de près
ce documentaire exclusif que nous venons de voir
son réalisateur Pierre Assouline est maintenant
avec nous sur ce plateau en compagnie de nos
autres invités Pierre Assouline bienvenue merci
c'est donc à vous que nous devons ce film vous
êtes réalisateur de documentairees journaliste
chroniqueur radio biographe romancier membre
entre autres du comité de rédaction du magazine
l'histoire que nous saluons d'ailleurs au passage
cette rédaction de l'histoire et aussi membre de
l'Académie concours et votre dernier livre
s'intitule le nageur publié chez galimar il
retrace le destin du nageur Alfred nakchee
sélectionné au JO de Berlin en 36 mais aussi
euh à ceux de Londres en 48 mais entre les deux
son histoire s'avère réellement hors du commun
et c'est cette histoire qui est à découvrir
sous votre plume aux éditions galimar bienvenue
François kersudi vous êtes historien spécialiste
de l'œuvre de De Gaulle et de Churchill dont vous
avez traduit et retraduit plus exactement en
français les mémoires de guerre de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale très exactement celle dont il
est question euh dans ce film que nous venons
de voir vous avez consacré une biographie
euh à church Chile mais aussi à de Gaulle
et vous avez par ailleurs consacré un livre
aux relations entre les deux hommes d'abord
écrit en anglais puis en français et votre
dernier ouvrage s'intitule 10 faces caché du
communisme et c'est un ouvrage à découvrir aux
éditions Perin enfin Jean-Luc Barret est avec
nous bienvenue Jean-Luc Barret très heureux de
vous recevoir vous êtes écrivain historien et
éditeur directeur des éditions boucin vous être
l'auteur entre autres de devenir de GO l'ouvrage
publié aux éditions Périn et plus récemment de
l'homme de personne 1890- 1944 premier volume
d'un tripticque biographique intitulé de Gaul une
vie publiée chez grassay et qui vous a d'ailleurs
valu le Prix renaudo essay les sorties des
deux autres volumes sont prévu en 2025 et
en 2027 pierreassouline on a peut-être besoin
de comprendre ce qui était votre intention le
Paris était risqué avec ce regard croisé entre les
mémoires de guerre de ces deux hommes à propos du
du second conflit mondial quelle était votre
intention sur le je suis parti d'abord de
l'admiration que je porte pour les deux
sur les deux hommes autant Churchill que de
Gaulle chacun pour des raisons différentes mais
c'est une admiration historique ensuite je suis
parti également ça se superpose d'une admiration
littéraire et d'un point de vue d'écrivain parce
que le point de vue des historiens a été développé
très souvent y compris à la télévision mais moins
on les a moins aperçu sur ce plan-là ou en tout
en tout cas envisager ou analyser et même comparer
sur ce plan-l et donc je trouvais intéressant de
de comparer d'abord première chose comment est-ce
qu'il pouvait raconter les mêmes événements mais
chacun à sa manière donc voir les deux phases d'un
même événement ça étant évident que c'est c'est
entre 40 et 45 à partir des mémoires de guerre
exclusivement et ensuite comparer les mérites
littéraires des deux je dois vous avouer mais
ça ça se perçoit dans le commentaire que mon
admiration littéraire admiration d'écrivain va
évidemment à de Gaulle qui pour moi est un grand
styliste et moins à le plus shakespearien des
deux n'est pas celui qu'on pense celon croitê
vous êtes davantage convaincu par le de GO
l'écrivain que Church l'écrivain absolument et ce
qui m'avit toujours surpris je dirais pas choqué
parce qu'il faut pas exagérer c'est qu'il ait pu
avoir le le le prix Nobel de littérature Marquet
lui-même a été surpris de la voir il voulait le
prix Nobel de la paix mais ce qui m'a surpris
c'est que finalement quand on voit les attendus
du comité Nobel on comprend que ils lui ont ils
l'ont décerné alors peut-être pour des raisons
diplomatique nous sommes quand même pas très
loin de l'après-gerre ou euh mais 1953 1953 mais
décerné avant tout à l'historien et à l'homme
des discours finalement on se demande si les
chef-dœuvres de Churchill se sont pas ces discours
et puis quand même dès qu'on creuse on s'aperçoit
bien entendu que il y avait derrière Churchill à
nombre de gens oui qui ont travaillé qu'on
découvre dans votre film pour ceux qui ne
savaient pas si [__] sont au service de de
Churchill c'est ce que vous dites dans ce film
qu'ppelle son synd il y a des Daco c'est
c'est un homme qui parle c'est un hom vous
appz le consortium Churchill finalement dans ce
film syndicaï comme il dit comme il disait mais
c'est un comment dire c'est un homme du verbe
et c'est un un formidable orateur donc c'est un
homme qui parle et qui raconte et à ça il est
impeccable mais pour moi le le styliste sur le
plan littéraire c'est c'est bien sûr de Gaulle
intéressant de de comparer les deux on va voir
ce qu'on pense François kersi c'est vrai que euh
souvent on dit qu'avec Kipling show Wells bien
Winston Churchill est l'un des quatre plus grands
écrivains britanniques du du 20e siècle c'est pas
tout à fait rien est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ce regard croisé porté par Pierre Assouline
et puis cette conclusion de de finalement préférer
l'écrivain de Gaul à l'écrivain Churchill alors
il faut voir plusieurs Chav de leur mémoire
de Guer ch d'abord ils ont pas ils ont pas
voulu écrire la même chose non plus ils ont voulu
faire chacun une œuvre c'est certain mais rien
qu'avec le titre vous voyez que l'ambition n'était
pas la même de Gaulle hein c'était mémoire de
guerre c'està-dire la France et moi moi au service
de la France turchill c'est pas ça hein de Second
World War hein la Seconde Guerre mondiale il il
il a pour ambition d'écrire toute l'histoire de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale donc forcément il va
pas faire la même chose bien entendu de temps en
temps assez souvent d' il intervient mais vous
avez des quantités des épisode de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale dans lequel il intervient pas
du tout hein la guerre du Pacifique la guerre
en Russie en Union soviétique il a rien à voir
là dedans mais il raconte etid comme il peut pas
tout raconter et bien il a recruté des gens pour
raconter à sa place et puis après il chur chilise
hein mais c'est c'est pas la même c'est pas la
même ambition au départ en ce qui concerne euh
alors les beaucoup de gens m'ont dire ah c'est
curieux qu'il a reçu le prix Nobel et cetera
et à chaque fois je dis mais vous l'avez lu en
anglais ou en français ils m'ont dit bon français
naturellement ah oui mais alors la traduction de
l'époque il faut voir comment était la traduction
de l'époque grâce à vous aujourd'hui on peut le
lire en français et moi je l'ai lu en partie en
anglais et dans votre version à vous ce n'est pas
si différent que ça ah si parce que la traduction
originaleis il y a de très
belles phrases c'est beau
rythmé le lecteur de ces lignes doit compr et
vous imitez parfaitement bien Winston Churchill
hein pour ceux qui n'auraient pas compris ou
mais le lecteur de CG doit comprendre combien
est opaque et déroutant le voile de l'inconnu
c'est beau quand même autrement dit convaincu
par ce qui était le style littéraire de Churchill
plus que celui de De Gaulle non non non non non
non chacun est un maître dans son domaine si on
si c'est pour dire de GA aurait mérité le prix
c'est tout à fait évident mais ils étaient
pas en compétition ils pouvaient pas le
l'ettre en ce qui concerne le prix Nobel ça
lui a été attribué on a effectivement fait
très attention de ne pas parler de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale parce qu'on savait effectivement
comment ça avait été rédigé mais ça lui a été
attribué d'ailleurs comme toujours le prix
Nobel pour l'ensemble de l'œuvre et l'ensemble de
l'œuvre c'est quoi 27 autres livres 400 articles
2583 10 discours et la différence est d'autant
moins marquée qu'il avait l'habitude de dicter
ses livres et d'écrire ses discours hein donc pour
lui il y avait effectivement pas pas vraiment de
différence vous l'avez dit he pierre assouine n'a
pas pris soin d'aller recevoir ce prix Nobel de
de la littérature en 53 à Stockholm parce que
lui il espérait le prix Nobel de était déçu de
l'APP Jean-Luc Barret euh je dirais que sur pour
de Gaulle il y a il y a l'idée d'un témoigner
de laisser un témoignage historique mais c'est
quand même une œuvre d'écrivain qu'il veut faire
parce que c'est je pense qu'il y a chez De Gaulle
peut-être un écrivain beaucoup plus encore que
chez chez chield d'abord il a écrit très jeune
des textes il a publié toute une série de livres
avec un soin particulier au style je ve dire donc
c'est un écrivain solitaire un homme qui travaill
énormment j'ai travaillé sur les les manuscrits
de ses mémoires et j'ai vu à quel point il
travaillait comme un écrivain véritablement avec
beaucoup de peine d'ailleurs texes r he parce que
vous avez retrouvé les originaux du côté de
la BNF he oui c'est très impressionnant très
impressionant et donc on peut dire que c'est pas
seulement on peut pas non plus se fier totalement
je je l'ai vérifié à travers la biographie que je
viens de rédiger au mémoir de guerre de De Gaulle
pour savoir la vérité exacte peut-être c'est plus
fiable parfois chez Churchill qui veut pas dire
qu'il y a pas un point de vue des deux côtés mais
voilà donc il y a a y a a chez De Gaulle le souci
d'abord de laisser une œuvre littéraire et de
construire son mythe c'est incontestablement les
mémoires de guerre sont là aussi pour construire
le myth de De Gaulle ceci étant c'est aussi un
Témo age superbe magnifique sur sur tout cela des
portraits extraordinaires le portrait de Churchill
le portrait d'Hitler le portrait de Staline
donc on a affaire quand même à une grande œuvre
un grand témoignage du du niveau de des grands
témoignages historiques hein de de de César ou
de du cardinal de ou parfois de Saint-Simon
d'ailleurs alors si j'ai bien compris la
chronologie hein Churchill a publié les six thôes
de ses Mémoires de guerre sur la Seconde Guerre
mondiale entre 48 et 53 et de Gaulle lui entre 54
et 59 autrement dit De Gaulle aurait pu jeter un
œil et plus qu'un œil sur les les mémoir écrit par
Churchill à l'époque puisqu'il sort les siennes
après cell de Churchill certainement d'autant
plus qu'il les avait à colomber dans son bureau
juste derrière lui on les voit d'ailleurs là donc
oui bien sûr sa curiosité était aiguisée aussitôt
faut imaginer quand même que la parution des
mémoires de Churchill c'est un succès considérable
c'est un événement mondial pas seulement en
langue anglaise mais dans le reste du monde
oui et les les gens comme le général d'ailleurs
on ont relut ont lu cette traduction eu donc il
ont pas ils sont pas intéressés à à l'original une
autre chose qui a scandalisé de Gaulle c'est que
euh Churchill les livre de Churchill a été publié
d'abord aux États-Unis et donc lui il disait
mais vous imaginez de Gaul être publié d'abord en
Belgique au Canada ce serait scandaleux et cetera
et et puis en plus euh les bonnes feuilles ont été
publiées dans Time et dans l' avant publication et
là aussi il était scandalisé hein est-ce que vous
imaginez vauvenar ou Saint-Simon se faire publier
dans les gazettes de Paris parce qu'il faut
jamais oublier s'agissant de churchy la dimension
financière c'estàd que ces écrits en général
mais depuis tout jeune he c'est un complètement
de revenu non non non c'est le revenu c'est pas
reven son revenu toute sa vie de sa plume c'est
ça qui est extraordinaire dès dès son plus jeune
âge quand il était encore à l'armée il envoyait
des articles qui étaient publiés dans la presse et
là la la la prépuation dans la il fait dans Time
bien sûr obéit à des considérations financières
évidentes donc ça ça ça compte beaucoup hein ah
bah oui il n'avait que ça comme revenu parce que
le le les les parlementaires étaient horriblement
mal payés der au début il était même pas du tout
et et en plus il avait un train de vie assez assez
somptueux donc rien que les mémoires de guerre
enfin les mémoir Second World War ça lui a
rapporté 550000 livres de l'époque ce qui fait 43
millions de dollars c'est important d'ailleurs de
dire aussi que pour de Gaulle dans cette période
làà de Gaulle n'a les seuls revenus réels de De
Gaulle vont être ses mémoires pendant toute une
période de de de sa vie en tout cas cette période
là des années 50 puisquil a refusé sa retraite
il a il ne voulait rien de voir à l'état c'est
d'ailleurs un mystère de savoir exactement de
quoi il a vécu dans cette période au-delà des
mémoires je pense que son frère qui était banquier
sans doute là ça fait par des éléments que que
j'essaierai de clarifier dans le dans le qu'il a
fait une donation à la Fondation Charles de Gaul
oui la Fondation Anne de Gaul oui oui bien sûr
mais en fait il fallait bien tout de même qu'il
vive et et une grande partie des mémoires lui ont
permis de vivre dans cette dans cette période là
puisqu'il avait des rapports avec à l'argent très
différents de ceux de Churchill je pense pas que
le train de vie soit comparable mais et donc il
avait mais il fallait effectivement dans la mesure
son indépendance passer aussi par par le fait
de gagner de l'argent avec ses mémoires juste un
mot quand même degal a porté un jugement sur les
mémoires de Churchill il y a une phrase où il dit
quel était-il ce jugement s'il fallait le résumer
il a dit c'est juste un bout à bout c'est juste un
bout juste un bout à bout oui c'est ça il a mis
bout à bout beaucoup de choses oui oui ce qui ce
qui est vrai et faux à la fois çap ça dépend des
chapitres alors ça nous amène sur les relations
ce qu'on été les relations entre les deux hommes
on les parcours pour un certain nombre d'entre
ell dans votre film Pierre Assouline la première
rencontre entre les deux hommes c'est le 9 juin
1940 ils ne se connaissent pas Churchill connaî
Paul Renault il connaît Mondel mais il conna endu
parler tout de même il a tout de même entendu
parler de de ce de il y a moncnet tout ça il a
entendu parler de ça mais ça reste très lointain
et de toute façon on sait très bien que c'est
pas lui qui l'attendait spécialement à Londres
donc c'est pour lui mais il y a quand même cette
rencontre plutôt Mel he qui l'attendait à oui en
il attendait tout le monde il attendait Mandel il
attendait peut-être daran il attendait peut-être
Bloom il a le seul qui qui qu'est-ce qui se
passe sur cette première rencontre et comment en
rendent-ils compte chacun de leur côté parce que
c'est souvent la bonne impression hein la première
impression l'impression on la connaî de de de
cherschill puisqu'il a parlé très vite de l'homme
du destin donc il a il aurait entrevu soi-disant
l'homme du destin je pense qu'il y a une part de
myth derilleurs tout ça quant à de Gaulle je pense
qu'il a il a tout de suite été impressionné
mais il l'avait vu il l'a retrouvé ensuite
à Londres avant même d'ailleurs le 18 juin donc
impressionné par effectivement la ce qui manquait
le plus à la France à ce moment-là au dirigeants
français c'est la volonté de se battre donc il y
a quand même quelque chose et puis chez De Gaulle
il y a le sens de du du personnage historique du
héros d'une certaine manière et incontestablement
voilà du connaable il le reconnaî il reconnaît ce
personnage là aussi chez chez Churchill connaable
c'est le surnom qu'on on donnait à don à voilà ou
absolument donc il y a quand même la rencontre
là de de deux personnages qui qui qui sont deux
hommes du destin d'une certaine manière et c'est
raconté à peu près de la même manière je pense des
deux des deux côtés alors l'homme du destin ça ça
aurait été l'expression utilisée par par Churchill
pour qualifier de Gaal après leur première
rencontre peu de temps après en tout cas c'est
la légende ou pas la légende pour répondre à ce
que vient de dire Jean-Luc Barret ça et Churchill
avait des intuitions fulgurantes c'est pas la
première hein il avait très curieuse capacité à à
voir dans l'avenir et à voir les possibilités par
ailleurs c'était aussi un propagandiste de génie
et donc l'homme du destin c'est parce qu'il avait
besoin d'un homme du destin et pourquoi est-ce
qu'il en avait besoin c'est parce qu'il voyait
bien que la France allait s'effondré d'ailleurs
la France s'est effondré et il avait très peur en
fait que les les Anglais cèdent pend la Première
Guerre mondiale les Français n'avaient pas cédé
et et donc les Anglais n'avaient pas été menacés
d'invasion là la France cède et d'un seul coup
il a peur que les politiciens parce qu'il y en a
disent bah voilà notre rempart sur le continent
à céd bah écoutez on va négocier avec Hitler et
et donc Churchill qui a une imagination fertile
propagandiste de génie il présente de Gou euh à
son opinion publique à ses députés en leur disant
vous croyez comme ça que la France a capitulé mais
non elle a pas capitulé puisqu'elle continue la
lutte euh grâce à ce c'est cet homme remarquable
de Gaulle hein fine fighting soldier with a good
reputation and strong personality alors en ce qui
concerne la strong personality évidemment il
aura l'occasion de regretter un peu plus tard
mais pour le moment c'est l'homme qu' lui faut
c'est l'homme du destin c'est l'homme pour de mon
destin qui va me permettre de d'encourager la la
la population euh les députés les ministres tous
ces gens qui sont assez rétissant quand même
hein à continuer le combat parce que la France
continue le combat à vos côtés vous voyez c'est
c'est l'imagination de l'homme et ça fonctionne
très bien je me dis que en vous écoutant que tous
les deux que finalement Churchill était avveit
de très bonnes intuitions sur de gale puisque
les deux biographes de De Gaulle ont repris des
expressions chur chilienne l'homme du destin pour
vous et le connaéable pour la couture pour Jean la
couture ce sont deux expressions de churchilleld
pour qualifier de Gaulle c'est que quand même il
avait bien senti le personnage alors que comme
vous le dites personnage à l'époque un inconnu
ce sont d'ailleurs c'est c'est curieux parce que
finalement durant toutes ces années 30 ils sont
ils sont pratiquement les seuls écarné une forme
de de résistance et de lucidité par rapport à leur
opinion leur gouvernement vis-à-vis du danger
du danger qui est en face de de nous c'estàd le
danger nazi et cetera ils sont ils sont assez
solitaires finalement ils se rencontrent aussi
parce qu'ils ont partagé à un moment donné les
mêmes les mêmes alarmes les mêmes inquiétudes
et les même combat oui mais à l'époque deg n'est
pas un homme public non mais il écrit des livres
il dit des choses bien sûr non maisch lui-même est
dans une situation pas oui bien sûr évidment bon
il reste quand même que Churchill a l'essentiel
de sa carrière politique derrière lui il a 60 ans
40 et donc 16 ans de plus que que de Gaulle et
de Gaulle lorsqu'il rencontre pour la première
fois church n'est que sous-secrétaire d'État à
la Guerre et à la défense nationale autrement dit
quand de Gaulle arrive à à Londres c'est un obligé
c'est un obligé or être être un obligé pour de GA
c'était pas quelque chose de très naturel du tout
le sentiment qu'il veut avoir d'ailleurs mon livre
s'appelle l'homme de personne aussi c'est pas par
hasard parce que l'homme de personne c'est une
formule qu'il a employé en août 40 quand on lui
a demandé en quelque sorte de se présenter parce
que les Anglais voulaient le faire connaître et
au lieu de dire voilà Charles de Gaulle né à né à
tel à tel moment et à telle date et je bon il dit
je suis l'homme de personne c'est une façon de se
présenter et c'est c'est déjà une forme de défi
euh vis-à-vis des Anglais pas seulement vis-à-vis
des Anglais d'ailleurs m dit je ne suis l'homme
d'aucun parti d'aucun politicien je n'appartiens
qu'à la France et à Dieu bon et donc c'est déjà
une manière de se de se singulariser par rapport à
Churchill on attend pas ça de de G on attend tout
de même d'un homme qui est financé hébergé par les
Anglais peut-être un peu plus de d'humilité mais
mais d'emblé il est dans un dans une posture qui
est celle de l'intransigence et il sait très bien
alors on pourrait rajouter à cela qu'il est pas
spécialement anglophile que culture n'est pas non
je dirais pas anglophobe mais non mais il est pas
anglophile il est plus il est plus germanophile
qu'il n'est anglophile dans sa culture donc il
connaît mal l'Angleterre il connait mal ce pays et
puis il a il a tous les souvenirs j'allais dire il
disait tout le temps je vous dis les choses depuis
1000 ans il avait des souvenirs quasiment de 1000
ans de relation entre la France et l'Angleterre
donc tout ça c'était c'était ça compte pour un
homme comme De Gaulle cette mémoire elle compte
là où chchill est un homme effectivement que je
dirais plutôt francophile en tout cas qui aime
la France et cetera c'est ça fait une différence
majeure entre les deux deg est très méfiant
c'est ça il est très méfiant il est il est pas
anclophobe comme son père l'était lui euh Lane il
les soupçonne d'un tempas de crime dont beaucoup
sont imaginaires d'ailleurs il le soupçonnera d'êt
anglophobe il ah oui mais ça c'était une façon de
de voilà s'il faisait pas les concessions il
était donc anglophobe voilà mais c'est c'est
pas vraiment ce qu'il y a ce que Churchill n'a
jamais compris c'est ce que disait tout le temps
de Gaulle je suis trop faible pour faire des
concessions alors évidemment pour pour chchill
c'est pas compréhensible hein c'est quand on est
faible qu'on fait les concessions pour de Gaulle
c'est le contraire hein et euh Churchill est aussi
quelqu'un évidemment de très autoritaire hein
euh tout ce que je demande c'est qu'on
se plie à ma volonté après un temps de
discussion raisonnable il demande pas grandchose
il demande que ça de Gaul avec ga ça marche pas
du tout c'est les intérêts de la France doivent
être sauvegardés on va voir un extrait du film
parce qu'il y a un trè homme qui va se mettre
entre entre de Gaul et Churchill et c'est celui
qui préside la plus grande puissance mondiale de
l'époque c'est Roosevelt nous parlâes de Roosevelt
et de son attitude à mon égard ne brusqu rien dit
Monsieur Churchill voyez comment tour à tour je
plie et me relève vous le pouvez observaije parce
que vous êtes assis sur un état solide une nation
rassemblée un empire uni de grandes armées mais
moi où sont mes moyens pourtant j'ai vous le savez
la charge des intérêts et du destin de la France
c'est trop lourd et je suis trop pauvre pour que
je puisse me courber monsieur Churchill conclut
notre entretien par une démonstration d'amitié et
d'émotion nous avons encore de rudes obstacles
à surmonter mais un jour nous serons en France
peut-être l'année prochaine en tout cas nous y
serons ensemble je ne vous lâcherai pas on est
sans doute au moment de crise pass le le plus fort
entre les deux hommes l'opération torche fin 42 et
puis cette conférence à Casablanca dont nous avons
ramener les images avec ce jeu avec Giro soutenu
par par Roosevelt et church hein là on est au au
plus fort de de ce qu'ont été les tensions entre
les deux il y aura d'autres encore d'autres
moments de tension et notamment juste avant
la libération au moment du débarquement dont de
Gaulle ne sera pas et donc ça va être très crispé
même l'arrivée de Churchill à Paris ça va pas
se faire aussi facilement qu'on le croit donc
ça c'est l'image d'Épinal par la suite avec le
recul a bien arrangé tout ça mais quand on lit
les mémoires et les lettres les correspondances
euh c'est à chaque fois on a l'impression que ça
va rompre entre eux en fait il il n'était pas fait
pour se pour s'aimer tellement les tempéraments
les caractères sont sont aux antipodes l'un de
l'autre mais après ça s'arrange en tout cas là
c'est vrai que avec le l'opération torche
l'arrivée de Roosevelt qui va en permanence
essayer de convaincre chchill de prendre ses
distances avec ce Français insupportable ça
va créer quelque chose de très très dur moi
j'admire j'admire finalement la résistance
Churchill vis-à-vis de Roosevelt Churchill aurait
eu ce mot je je vous a le citer à la conférence de
de Casablanca justement son pays a abandonné
la lutte lui-même n'est qu'un réfugié et si
nous lui retirons notre appluie c'est un homme
fini et bien regardez-le dit-il en parlant de
Gaulle non mais regardez-le on croirait Staline
avec 200 divisions derrière lui voilà ça c'était
c'était du turchill s'exprimant sur De Gaulle
à cette fameuse conférence de de Casablanca
il y a d'autres moment très for de tension le
débarquement de Gaulle n'est mis au courant que
le 4 juin le débarquement a lieu 2 jours plus
tard notamment très forte tension s'il fallait
en garder un ou deux de ces moments de très forte
tension entre les hommes ça serait lesquels pour
vous ah pour moi ça serait le le le Liban en 43
et la Syrie en 45 pour lesquels d'ailleurs il
faut bien le dire les mémoires de De Gaulle
ne sont pas fiables du tout hein euh il est
contredit sur sa version des événements par C les
archives de C pays différents et par ses propres
archives c'est-à-dire que alors c'est ce qui est
sympathique chez De Gaulle si vous voulez c'est
que il ne ment pas pour se mettre en valeur il
ment pour mettre en valeur la France et il se
trouve que en 43 à beroutth et en 4 5 à Damas
le rôle de la France du fait des personnes qui
étaient en charge à l'époque a été parfaitement
lamentable et donc il ne pouvait pas raconter la
vérité hein et et donc qu'est-ce qu'il fait et
bien il invente un complot britannique dans les
deux cas c'est la faute des anglais c'est pas
la faute de mon représentant sur place qu' a
rappelé d'ailleurs dans les deux cas parce que il
s'était très mal comporté mais il fallait pas que
ça sache donc les les mémoires sont à la glire
de la France donc la France ne peut pas s'être
trompée mais dans ses archives sur le Levant en
par particulier on voit très bien que il savait
la vérité il la savait parfaitement mais il
pouvait pas la dire donc il a inventé il il y
a des passage comme ça il faut dire c'est du roman
feilleton oui les moments de tension il y en a eu
tout de suite en fait il y en a eu tout de suite
parce qu'il y a eu autant de de personnag on a
toujours cherché quelqu'un qui pourrait finalement
écarter de Gaul et le remplacer ça a été il y a
même un moment où chchill a sondé Catrou pu final
Catrou a fait acte d'allégence immédiatement à de
George Catrou qui était un a d'ailleurs plus
gradé que de Gaulle mais qui avait accepté de
d'une certaine manière de de reconnaître que de
Gaulle c'était la France et peu importe finalement
le nombre d'étoiles qui avaient sur leur KPI et
puis il y a eu la tentative prolongée de de de
mettre Muselier en scène on a oublié mais c'est
ce n'est pas rien je relate assez longuement
d'ailleurs tout ce ce psychodrame degul avait pris
la mesure des autres il savait à peu près qu'il
n'avait pas grandchose à risquer de Girot et de
Muselier mais il n'empêche qu'ils avaient eux des
soutiens que lui n'avait pas et il avait notamment
vous parlez de de complot britannique je pense que
de GA pouvait à juste titre imaginer que tantant
il y avait des complots contre lui alors le le
cas du Levant est un peu est un peu particulier
mais euh et puis il y a eu Giro bien sûr et puis
l'épisode d'arland donc c'est autant de raisons
d'affrontement quasi permanent et accentué par le
par l'arrivée de rosevelt d'une certaine manière
dans dans dans dans la guerre dès l'instant que
les États-Unis entrent en guerre c'est le grand
large qu'il emporte sur sur tout le reste et donc
il y a quand même une collusion même une conivance
de Churchill avec avec Roosevelt très prolongé et
il a fallu tout de même que que de Gaulle et cette
capacité de de de résistance surtout qu'il est les
moyens de rassembler autour de lui la résistance
d'avoir des atouts extrêmement forts à opposer
à tout cela mais sans arrêt il a été sur le fil
parce que Roosevelt voulait d'une manière d'une
manière permanente la tête de De Gaulle en finir
avec de Gaulle et Churchill le soutenait tout en
étant dans l'équivoque qui était lié précisément
à cette relation avec privilégié qu'il avait avec
les États-Unis et de Gaul ne dir digérera jamais
de ne pas avoir été informé en temps et en heure
de ce débarquement et il n'ya aucune célébration
du débarquement par la suite alors il est il est
tout de même il est tout de même là il est tout
de même à Londres au moment où ça va mais mais
il est pas au courant de cela il est tenu à
l'écart et surtout le premier débarquement
dont il ignore tout c'est le débarquement
d'Afrique du Nord et et qui est d'ailleurs
assez baroque puisque finalement les vichistes
vont tirer sur les sur les alliés et cetera et
là ça nous ramène à novembre 42 le parol mais
vous avez admiré la la résistance de Churchill
par rapport à à à Roosevelt en fait elle était
extrêmement faible il a été obligé de résister
pourquoi parce que son cabinet et notamment
idon et Atle ont refusé la rupture avec de
Gaulle hein et et donc il a été obligé de dire
à et et le roi aussi et sa femme aussi et donc
il a été obligé de dire à à Roosevelt ben je suis
obligé le Parlement est maintenant pour de Gaulle
l'opinion publ et pour de Gaulle je peux pas je
peux pas rompre avec lui en fait c'est ça hein et
et donc il était ch de Gaul le comprenait très
bien il l'a dit hein Churchill me considère comme
un meuble bien encombrant auquel il se heurte de
temps en temps mais qui fait maintenant partie du
décor et qu'on ne peut plus déplacer il en jouit
il le savait à partir de 43 fin 43 il savaiit très
bien que les Anglais ne pouvaient pas céder à
à Roosevelt qui lui était effectivement atteint
d'une grave maladie c'est une golophobie aigue
hein et que bah ma fois il fallait supporter il
nous reste TR minutes vous avez commencé votre
film avec cette journée du du 30 janvier 65
sont les funérailles de national de Churchill
bien entendu de goliiva en spectacle spectacle
extraordinaire avec les grues qui se lèvent sur la
Tamise enfin c'est inoui inoui ouais il aurait eu
des mots très forts vis-à-vis de concernant
Churchill de De Gaulle à ce moment-là oui
mais c'est normal c'est la c'est la fin c'est la
réconciliation il y a plus de guerre il y a plus
de crise mais les 4 années quand même qui est qui
sont au centre de du documentaire c'est quand même
une tension permanente vous allez me dire c'est la
guerre oui d'accord mais tout de même ça n'arrête
pas une seconde enfin du côté de du côté de Gaulle
c'est il est tout tout le temps tout le temps dans
la guerre interne intérieure jerais juste évoquer
une chose c'est qu'il y a dans le documentaire
une archive que je trouve extraordinaire c'est
celle de la conférence d'enfa Casablanca où on
les voit répéter les mains vous allez serer une
deuxième fois la main de Giro c'est inoui et de
GA qui disaiit ça c'est çaoui une petite chose
et d'ailleurs Roosevelt a l'air de prendre un
malin plaisir à à refire la prise après guerre la
relation entre les deux hommes jusqu'à la mort de
jeis juste raconter une ENF une anecdote qui
qui qui est que j'ai découvert dans les dans
les mémoires de De Gaulle de Gaulle raconte ça
ça dit ça dit beaucoup de choses de la relation
entre les deux hommes et aussi du du goût du mythe
pas pas du mensonge mais deun façon de mythifier
l'histoire euh de GO raconte sa dernière rencontre
avec avec Churchill et Churchill al première
version de goécrit dit Churchill me dit amitié
puis de GA reprend et il remplace le mot amitié
il fait dire à Churchill vive la France c'est
extraordinaire parce que c'est c'est tout à fait
et évidemment c'est le dernier au fond le dernier
affrontement il est littéraire en quelque sorte
oui alors petite chose dans dans le film vous
dites Churchill maîtrisait bien le français c'est
très indulgent hein parce que Churchill massacrait
couramment le français mais son français c'était
de l'anglais décalqué hein poresque d'aurs
mot à mot donc et ch s'en rendait bien compte
puisqu'il a dit ceci à à à de Gaulle en janvier
44 à à Casablanca euh maintenant que le général
parle si bien l'anglais il comprend parfaitement
mon français oui effectivement il fallait parler
l'anglais pour comprendre le français de chch et
ce ce ce fameux jour du 30 janvier 65 funérail
de Churchill de Gaul en verra une lettre à
la reine ellisabeth i avec ses mots dans ce
grand drame il fut le plus grand un grand merci
vraiment à tous les trois d'avoir participé à
ce dbad dooc aujourd'hui sur la base de votre
film c'est il est exclusif pour notre chaîne
Pierre Assouline les réactions sont nombreuses
je l'imagine elles seront à trouver sur hashtag
desbadog vous pourrez réagir hein d'ailleurs à ce
que sont les les réactions de nos téléspectateurs
merci à Selma sali Sarah udline qui m'ont aidé à
préparer cette émission et je vous retrouve tout
simplement pour un prochain débat dooc ça sera
bien sûr avec son documentaire et son débat à très
[Musique]
bientôt